each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my distinct pleasure today to have
John San Giovanni joining us again for a
talk on the mobile space that he's been
so deeply involved with for the last
four years as part of a start-up and
John will be telling you some of his
background but as many of you know he
worked in microsoft research for eight
years as part of external research
funding a lot of great innovation in the
mobile space but more recently John's a
co-founder and now a vp of design
product design at ozumo be this startup
and he's got tons of great insights
about the mobile space and what's going
on there so please welcome him awesome
thank you very much um dudes so exciting
to be back at MSR amazing I eight years
that I spent in these halls were you
know the most exciting and illuminating
that in my professional career and it's
always an honor to come back as I would
always say when I was show up to work in
the morning I would show up to the
building and the average IQ would drop
by 50 points so that when I went home
and I did spike back up so but it's an
incredibly energetic place and I
continue to be inspired by the output
not only with microsoft research but of
the intellectual horsepower of the
employees at microsoft it's an
incredibly energetic place and i
continue to find it inspiring so thanks
for your hospitality and looking really
forward to spending some time today we
have lots of interesting things to talk
about so I think you know this this talk
today is going to be centered around a
topic that is you know sort of all the
rage right now which is mobile
advertising and specifically I've
decided to break the talk into three
parts the first is I'm going to talk a
little bit about the history of the zoo
mobi network because it was born in
these halls and has a really kind of
interesting tale it's a spin out and
we'll talk a little bit about how you
know the incubation process inside
microsoft research and then how it's
spun out to be this independent entity
second of all i want to talk about this
phenomenon that's fairly new called
mobile engagement advertising in the
sense that you know we tend to simplify
the types of advertising as you know
words or banners or micro sites and
actually I think that if you look at the
different
of advertising there's a very
interesting new segment emerging within
the context of mobile devices and mobile
apps so I'm going to talk about that and
that'll sort of anchored the talk and
then lastly I wanted to talk a little
about what happens next and my intention
for that portion is to have it be very
much of an audience driven conversation
and talk about whatever and the in
mobile or in mobile advertising you have
an interest in or you have questions
about but also I do want to address a
couple things up address windows phone 7
also want to talk about html5 and what's
happening there but I really want that
to be an audience driven conversation so
so first of all I want to kind of talk
about this space of fact there we go the
space that I call super phones and we
actually try to recast the if you
stratify the different mobile devices
kind of feature phones smartphones super
fun I think a lot of times people dump
all these devices in as smartphones but
actually think that super phones are
distinctly different in a bunch of ways
first of all they're largely consumer
focus when you think about a smartphone
value proposition you know for years and
years that was very much around email
and messaging and enterprise workers
whereas superphones iphone android
windows phone seven palm webos others
are very much about apps and social and
communication and they're really as much
targeted for consumers that they are for
knowledge workers but this is all
predicated on this you know kind of new
platform a set of platform features
which means you know kind of rich media
capabilities robust development tools
hardware accelerated graphics full
fidelity browsers all these things that
have come together to really create a
new category of device so you know I
think for a long time every one of these
discussions about mobile phones or about
mobile advertising sort of devolved into
an iPhone love fest and I think now it's
time to recast that conversation and
kind of talk about it as a segment of
the market place because there's a bunch
of players in the market and it's an
interesting way to kind of look at this
industry so that's the context and we
actually coined this term a couple of
over a year ago now and now it's been
picked up by Google and by venture
capitalists and others that are using
this as a way to to talk about this so
yeah Jim
is a difference that between lex a brew
and this is it just that the innovation
kept living the developers is different
said I because brew is pretty much
insurance brokers appstore driven
Qualcomm sure sure fair point I think
the caveat is that the so the question
was you know what about something like
brew which was consumer-focused once
upon a time in the qualcomm universe and
I think the answer is that it's all
about frictionless distribution of these
little app experiences you know like for
example on Windows Mobile back in two
thousand i was you know on a subway in
New York and downloaded a cab file of a
subway map and was using it and that was
a nap and that was designed for
consumers that was you know a decade ago
I think now what we're seeing is that
there's because the an end user
developer or publisher doesn't have to
flow through carrier relationships
doesn't have to try and get placement on
a deck that frictionless distribution
channel together with you know really
robust development capabilities has
really forged a new category and it's
also the hardware right it's a direct
manipulation touchscreen if you google
super fun I sort of laid out a bulleted
list of how we define what the super
phone segment is about it has
location-based services through real gps
there's a collection of specific
platform features that really define
something as a superphone in our eyes
but i think it's kind of an important
way to kind of segment the industry and
these are the five devices that that
there's a movie network addresses we you
know we're on blackberry and actually
the new blackberry 6 platform that just
shipped with the torches is a real
honest-to-goodness superb own super
phone platform now I think for the first
time the palm pre webOS platform and and
the pixi as well of course iPhone iPod
Touch google android and soon windows
phone 7 and we're excited to be working
on that platform now so mobile
advertising sort of goes with that
explanation but if you're not in this
space this is an incredibly exciting
time in mobile advertising I think
there's been a lot of false starts
around mobile advertising and everybody
said that sort of next year is the year
when mobile advertising would become
real from our perspective that was last
year 2009 was really the year and the
way we qualify that is its when the
advertising spends from the agencies
move from sort of the experimental
budget where they sort of throw a lot of
things against the wall to where it's an
action
line item in the advertising budget
where they're actually spending real
dollars year-over-year around a brand on
mobile and these numbers reinforce that
and importantly the app space
specifically is an incredibly hot space
in the segment of mobile advertising you
know fifty two percent of super phone
users claim they've they've acted on an
in-app ad eighteen percent of made a
purchase directly from an in-app ad it's
a very kind of active audience and in
fact so much so that we have partnered
really nicely with Microsoft advertising
to be able to take some of our
inventories we have a lot of Microsoft
specific properties as you'll see but
even the properties that aren't
Microsoft specific content properties
we're collaborating with the Microsoft
advertising team for them to sell as
part of an integrated by so a lot of
times these campaigns will be across
Bing and the xbox you know dashboard and
also on the super phone apps so that's
sort of a nice integrated way to do it
integrated by across multiple platforms
okay so I want to kind of set up for the
context of the talk and provide a thesis
for what what I'm going to talk about in
the context of our brief time together
today when we look at advertising in
general over the course of a hundred
years you know if you look at kind of
key media pillars across that time
usually there's this continuum between
brand advertising and performance
advertising right so if you look at
television obviously the line is here
the vast majority of advertising on
television is you know Network spots
there's a tiny sliver of performance
oriented advertising which is like QVC
or late-night infomercials to which I'm
uncontrollably drawn but for the most
part it's all about 30-second spots
about brand advertising about product
launches stuff like that if you look at
the web the exact opposite right the
vast majority of web buys our
performance oriented search words CPM
cost-per-click stuff like that that's
very very much a performance-oriented
medium and there is some segments of
micro sites or viral video campaigns and
that still happens the agencies are
still partying in that place but the
split is the opposite which leaves the
question which of these things will
mobile be and if you look at mobile I
think most people are predisposed to
believe that the split looks a lot like
it does on the web and I think that if
you were to categorize those it would
look something like this
where you have you know a vast majority
of again search CPM cost per click some
local map oriented advertising and then
there's a little sliver of what we call
kind of advertisement which is different
than what zoom OB does today we did a
couple of them in a previous life but
this is really branded apps where you
actually go and you download the Pepsi
app or the tide app or the BMW app and
you you know shake the phone and
something fun happens and you show it to
a friend but for the most part you
uninstall it within 48 hours so that's
but that's you know kind of brand
advertising on mobile but it's all about
downloading and ingesting that brand you
know icon on your home screen the space
that we're focused in and the space that
is you know we've been focusing on
really for the last two years is this
intermediate segment here which you know
i'll refer to as sort of mobile
engagement and the reason why this is
different is that it's kind of in many
ways the best of both worlds it is not a
free-standing app it's actually a little
act within an app so it's served as part
of another content property so you might
be in the official app for the Today
Show and then when you go into the
recipe section you'll you'll have a call
to action to drill in and have a brand
experience around you know food brand or
about you know so that's really what
this engagement oriented advertising is
but it has the best of both worlds
because it has very deep engagement
advertising can do video playback social
media interop you know response forms a
lot of the things that you would expect
to find in a branded app but it's very
targeted because it's served as part of
an existing audience that's already
using an automotive app or already using
a gaming app or something like that so
in that way it's very nice in the sense
that it's very targeted and of course it
also has incredible metrics on the back
end so you know exactly how much time
somebody spends in the different
portions of that experience and it's
very lush kind of very creative so the
good news is that this new segment of
advertising is I think in many ways the
best of both worlds the challenge is
that it's it's complicated because you
do need some creative horsepower it's
not sort of a self-service
fire-and-forget form of advertising and
there's a lot of complexities to the
ecosystem to make those types of
advertising work this is again all over
the news right now you've certainly seen
I add as I mentioned our brand blast
platform has been
early in the space for two years and we
have a lot of learnings from that which
I'll talk about and a little bit more a
little bit more detail yeah it's sort of
you know an app within an app is another
way to describe it so you go into an app
that you use every day because you're
you have an affinity towards some
segments of content and then inside that
content you get a integrated brand
experience that's it's not a banner
doesn't throw over the wall to a browser
it's an in-app you know kind of brand
experience i'll show you some examples
advertisement so the advertisement is
sort of a brand experience in and of
itself that you go to the app store and
you search for tide and you install the
tide you know stain buster app or
whatever and that's sort of a value the
value proposition is around the
advertiser themselves and usually those
apps are built by an agency and they
have typically a fairly short life you
know it'll be it'll have a couple of
weeks of activity around a new car
launch or something like that and the
user isn't likely to kind of keep that
in their home screen month over month
over month they're more likely to sort
of experience it in the go away whereas
mobile engagement advertising is going
to be served into a Content property
around that same around the same time
but the content property will stay on
their phone for months or years since
its do the conditions over it's not a
motivator to discovery like an app store
you don't go because you're naughty got
it right intentionally because you don't
want to just attract people who are
outie you want to go to the automobile
app and serve you know kind of an audi
brand experience inside the context of
that audience that's right and I'm not
saying that there's not there's not a
market for that other segment I think
advertisements will live on in some
segments that's an agency business
that's just not the business that we're
interested in and and curiously no one's
really i mean you know i ad is really in
this space and brand blasters in this
space but this is a very important space
not just in the context of you know
iphone but in mobile software going
forward because i think this funds some
very interesting directions in mobile so
i'll speak to that briefly just for
context many of you have kind of
followed the zoo movie adventures since
we were part of microsoft but just to
get you up to speed of sort of where we
are now zoom OB is kind of the the
premium mobile app network across all
the platforms that i showed before kind
of in the superphone space but
importantly we kind of think about this
space very
differently first of all the the way
that these the model works for us is
that we don't you know this not motor
trend approaches us check in hand and
says hey we want you to build a mobile
app no we're an advertising company so
you know mercedes-benz will approach us
check in hand and say we're interested
in this audience we're interested in you
know automotive enthusiasts who are you
know in this age range and this gender
and we want to really speak to that
audience and then zoom OB will then in
turn look for current properties that
are already in our network or new
properties that we can approach and
bring into the zoo mobile network that
really address that audience so in this
case you know motor trend is is a
perfect example where it's you know
squarely in the target audience of that
Mercedes was looking for and then we
work collaboratively with the motor
trend at at reddit oriole team to
lovingly craft a you know a motor trend
content experience we put it into one or
more app stores across the platforms
that motor trend and Mercedes are
interested in and then it's the app goes
to market a coincident with the campaign
and that basically funds a portion of
the development of the app but the app
lives on and attracts an audience going
forward this is cool for a couple
reasons first of all it's good for
everyone because Mercedes gets exactly
the audience that they wanted it's good
for sumo be because it's a very
lucrative targeted advertising by it's
good for source interlink the publisher
of motor trend because not only do they
get a revenue share on that advertising
revenue but they also get an app for
free and it's actually good for the end
user because the end user gets an app
that might have otherwise been the buck
or two they get that app for free and
instead of getting sort of assaulted by
banner advertising they get this very
elegant kind of lovingly crafted brand
in you know branded content so it's a
really really nice ecosystem in that way
and we've focused our business
exclusively on that so we've done this
model a bunch of times now we did the
official app for MSNBC the official app
for today show a bunch of sporting
properties and partnership with the
sporting news the official app for xbox
which I'll talk about the official app
for Better Homes and Gardens the TLC
television network parenting magazine
automobile magazine American Idol a
bunch of these properties that really
are attracted to this model of you know
kind of it's an advertising business and
I would say that this mom
model of advertising really speaks to an
interesting future of mobile software in
general because the reality is that it
is extraordinarily hard to make a
business out of a Content app given that
so many of the apps are free that
there's very few consumers that are
willing to pay more than a couple bucks
if anything at all for a Content app
games totally different this
conversation is not about games I think
people will pay for games but for
content apps we believe that the most
lucrative option for a publisher is to
use this kind of integrated high value
sponsorship mobile engagement
advertising so that's our observation
and that kind of gives you context of
where we are today so I figured in
telling the story of zoo mobi it's sort
of interesting to see where we are today
it kind of has an interesting backstory
you might not have known that microsoft
owns a portion of one of the largest
super phone app networks and how is that
the case so we'll talk about that but I
wanted to start with where we are today
and then we'll go back and tell you how
we how we got here sort of Christopher
Nolan style you let you publish are they
apps within the apps are they to ask
them so those are the publishing
properties and this will become more
clear when you see examples of each so
every one of those that I showcased in
that string and I'd intentionally made
the microfiche because we'll talk about
them later they're so those are the
actual publishing properties and those
live on if you have an iPhone or Android
or you know Palm webOS device in your
pocket you can search the App Store for
zoom obion you'll get one or more of
these apps so this story has an
interesting genesis as I mentioned it
was born inside Microsoft Research and
you know my role at microsoft was a
really interesting and exciting one I
was actually recruited in 1999 to be
focused exclusively on mobile I've
worked in mobile and specifically in
mobile content my entire career and my
role was split up into three very
distinct elements at Microsoft so the
first one was kind of academic grant
funding and research around mobile
researchers so the goal there was to try
and get mobile research scientists
excited about Microsoft platforms and I
was actually mentored from a bunch of
old-school Microsoft evangelists from
the old legendary developer relations
group Todd Needham and others that help
sort of teach me how you know
gorilla evangelism work so one of the
things that I do is I'd show up to an
academic conference and you know see who
the who the best presenters were that
we're doing interesting things on other
mobile platforms java j2me or or palm
and then by the time they got back to
their University now they returned from
Copenhagen they show up to their office
and there's a you know a care package
from Microsoft with a classroom full of
pocket pcs and dev tools and books and
lo and behold there next research
project was on Microsoft platform so it
was very cool evangelism strategy you
remember these devices so this was some
of the devices remember i started 99 so
this is an interesting progression of
mobile devices and it's it's a it's a
cell phone but it's also a mobile
computer together so but microsoft was
country before country was cool as the
song goes so that was part of my job and
that was a lot of fun and had a lot of
impact on the marketplace and in fact
specifically the dotnet compact
framework and microsoft mobile devices
in general really became the primary way
that academic research scientists did
dramatic things on mobile after eight
years of this focused effort the second
thing was more traditional large format
event delivery so I traveled all over
the world in some cases more than 90
city stops a year throughout the US and
Europe and India and China doing talks
about Microsoft mobile strategy and to
you know 72 7,000 people and that was
really fun and incredibly again
illuminating to kind of see what people
were doing dramatic things people were
doing with Microsoft platform
technologies and and it was it was a lot
of fun and we I think we catalyzed a lot
of really great innovation and mobile in
general so that was really thrilling the
third thing that I did was this concept
of themed research partnerships and
Microsoft Research does this to this day
where it's really a highly focused
multi-year million-dollar research
agenda focused around a specific theme
and the two that I'll talk about one is
I had a relationship with the NYU center
for advanced technology specifically
around Ken purlin and that was around
this really cool kind of single-handed
gestural text input system which don't
worry I won't talk about today those of
you in this room are sick of hearing me
talk about that but but it actually was
a really cool system was focused on kind
of the the expanding
sphere of high-speed textures and it was
a really novel non handwriting
non-speech non typing eyes free way to
do you know in some cases 40 words per
minute with one hand without looking it
was designed for the kind of teenage
mutants in Helsinki but it was actually
really pretty cool in fact Bill Gates
freakishly good at this may picked it up
first try a Bill Gates I get it no
errors guy's a badass so anyways that
was a really cool project and the second
thing that we did was the University of
Maryland human-computer interaction lab
was doing interesting work about around
zooming zooming user interfaces consumer
interfaces for for you know consuming
content and specifically been better
ssin and his team at Maryland was
incredible and so we started funding the
the center and then Amy Carlson joins in
there after and was an important
cornerstone of that partnership as well
so that actually is the catalyst to to
what became what is now sumo be this was
something called launched I'll so we
work together on this concept this
project of you know what if your cell
phone had a big touchscreen and there
was this was 2004 so you know what if
your cell phone had a big touchscreen
and you were able to download these we
called them tiles but essentially apps
over the air and you could consume them
using a really sexy kind of hardware
accelerated graphics interface for
consuming this content you could go
customize your home screen however you
wanted to you could virally send those
tiles to other friends there was a big
social media component to it it was a
really really fun project and it's
important for me to pause here and say
that this was an incredibly cool
cross-disciplinary cross-divisional
collaborative effort the there were many
people far smarter than I am that had
you know kind of significant
contributions to this work so central
among them dr. been better ssin who many
of you know who to this day is actually
a chief scientist of the zoo movie
network he's still at the University of
Maryland in in College Park Maryland but
he he's out in Seattle every month or so
and still provides that you I
perspective and that rich research
perspective Amy Carlson who's in the
room was actually the first author on
the
academic paper about launched I'll that
was nominated for best paper at Chi in
2005 and it's because of her diligence
and follow stated she kept Ben and I
online and we the thing was built at all
and then lastly Erin clam edge who you
might not know but who's a brilliant
developer at the University of Maryland
who who lovingly crafted much of the
code I also want to mention not only
Daniel Robbins who actually was the
co-author of the core patent of this
system because he had done the the zone
zoom work that inspired this design but
the rest of the vibe team and really all
of MSR I mean we had incredible access
to you know Andy Wilson and Dan Rosen
thumb well people all over the company
who provided incredible input on this so
this was I just want to make it clear
this was an incredibly collaborative
effort across the entire entire company
at the time it wasn't deemed to be a you
know the strategic imperative on the
product planning and that's not a
criticism you know the product teams are
very complex there's a lot of moving
parts there's different focuses at the
time think about a two thousand four the
theme was very much about blackberry
compete it was very much about knowledge
workers and about sort of taking market
share away from blackberry and at the
time there was probably a lot more
revenue opportunity there than there was
and kind of consumer or advertising
opportunities so when it was determined
together with the windows mobile senior
executive management specifically yah
Chen that it wasn't necessarily a
perfect direct fit for Windows Mobile's
product family then we did something
very exciting so I want to pause there
for a second i want to show you where it
was because it's interesting progression
to watch and so this is this is the
juicers compa to do and of that original
design tabular made in 2004 the land
space is divided into now you can see
there's this new space and there's these
tiles yuusha and you can zoom in and out
this is actually the first time that
anybody have used this num kind of
concept of a physical space on top of a
little pain inside a window but also
this direct manipulation dragging which
now of course is commonplace on mobile
phones this is one of the first times
that it's the interaction technique was
ever employed on a mobile phone for you
know tiles on a screen i be used for map
navigation use for other things but so
anyways this was this was really the
the basic concept of launch tile and
this is it a cross platform on on other
devices as well so that was a kind of an
interesting blast from the past so
pressing forward this is when we should
mention the Microsoft IP Ventures
program because this is a very cool
release valve where they basically
determined all right if this isn't in
the immediate product plans mobile
advertising is an important segment you
know consumer focused content is a very
important segment and it's an incredible
credit to LCA and to the patent team who
said let's work on a packaging effort to
package this up and spend it off to an
independent company so that's what was
done and and all these individuals were
central to that specifically Sharif
Mansoor who you know navigated the very
complex technical business and political
landscape to really package this up
effectively also Jim Cooley who is the
technical advisor inside IP ventures who
eventually joined the venture and became
our chief technology officer for a
number of years David Harnell who's
running the group at the time and Brad
Bernal and Todd Herman who really
brought an advertising business model
perspective into the mix and this
program was successful they launched a
bunch of companies actually very
exciting and we still have regular
interaction with the IP ventures group
in fact they to this day have board
observer rights on our board of
directors and they show up to almost
every board meeting and participate and
provide input and feedback so you know
this is a whole dimension of Microsoft
partnership that most people don't
recognize Microsoft is you know been
incredibly objective and effective at
being able to bring ideas like this to
life so then that brings us to Zen Zhu
Li you might have heard Zen Zoe we
eventually rebranded to zoom OB because
consumer insight tests showed that Zen
Zoe was was either a agen restaurant or
a spa and nobody thought it was a mobile
startup so we so we rebranded the
company but but this was exciting we
were funded by by oak investment partner
partners largest private equity firm in
the world Co very venture xand also
Microsoft as I mentioned it still has an
equity stake in the company in exchange
for the intellectual property that we
took out of the company and this is just
a snapshot of some of the important
people outside of the Microsoft gene
pool that helped really you know bring
this prodding this product into a
network and so at the top is Tom Hughes
be a seattle-area wireless venture
capitalist everything
you know everything that you'd want a VC
to be Thomas those things and all the
horror stories you hear about VCS he's
none of those things he's an amazing
professional he's also incredibly smart
and technical and then a whole group of
other people that helped advise and
direct the company and the bottom
picture is is Ken willner our current
CEO who's one of the top people in the
planet on mobile advertising he ran
mobile advertising at eighteen t for
years and it was really his vision that
brought us into this network so let me
stop there and show you what zoom OB was
when it launched because that's also
kind of a fun thing you see you know the
first video you see is this very
researchy zooming you I prototype and
then that leads to in early 2007 this
you
so I won't subject you the rest of music
but the point is that we we made
incredible progress we got faster we got
real brands in fact every one of the
brands did you see there is tiles in
many cases that was their first foray
into mobile this was the first mobile
app for MTV and for NPR we had
incredible partnerships with Nike on the
brand side I mean it was a really really
fun adventure and importantly it really
put us in the app headspace way before
anybody else was in the app headspace
because we were thinking about how how
the advertising model should work we
were thinking about the technical
problems the feed processing on the
backend the ad serving issues it was a
very exciting time and in fact it was an
incredibly complicated piece of software
so it had you know we had a
cross-platform tile SDK it had
resolution adaptation we were running on
Windows Mobile and blackberry full
metrics reporting including offline
metrics reporting which still hasn't
even done local caching zooming you I at
the time the.net compact framework team
claimed that it was the most complex
piece of software ever written on
the.net CF so it sounds great right we
know what what could possibly have gone
wrong at this point well it was to use
that experience with all those features
on that hardware it was pretty
craptacular thank you for your nods I
appreciate candor but it was it was a
basically the the platform crushed under
the weight of all these complexities and
what we really wanted was a more focused
content experience or a more powerful
computing platform so we led to this
strategy which we called Zumo before
which was really interesting because
rather than thinking about selling the
consumer on getting a player and then
having them select tiles inside that
player we said why don't we curate some
tiles around a specific content category
and then let's get it advertising
financed and we let's distribute it as
an individual module again you can see
how this is a very clear way point to
the zoo movie network as it lives today
it really got us thinking about content
thinking about merchandise and content
and actually with this sorry about that
with this we actually this was when we
launched our cross-platform effort where
we went blackberry and windows mobile
the initial plan was jus symbian next
because there was an effort
aachen to get dotnet on to symbian a
Microsoft effort but ultimately the the
marketing environment was was better for
blackberry so we did the official app
for the Beijing Olympics and this was
the first app that we did across all
three platforms so we did windows
windows mobile blackberry and then at
the last minute as part of a skunkworks
effort that was going in parallel we
took the same tile code and we actually
ship diversion for iphone as well and
this was not the modular expandable you
know zoomable tile interface this was a
specific zooming you I around the
Olympics content the same content that
was in the other phones and so we
invested in we were top tier dotnet
partner we'd invested tons of effort
into this kind of big platform and then
we launched this literally less than a
month after the App Store went live it
was actually the first advertising
sponsored content app in the App Store
and it might be in its interesting in
retrospect to talk about what percentage
of usage were so again the App Store
been open less than a month how many
users do you think iphone would get
fifteen percent twenty percent of the
whole rather than telling you how many
users that got i'll tell you how many
users the other two platforms got it was
pretty staggering so 98 fully
ninety-eight percent of the usage was on
this crazy strange new platform and that
was you know from the perspective of our
board of directors it was staggering
with regard to how important this was
going to be in the marketplace and so we
decided to take advantage of all the
backends feed processing an ad serving
technology that we'd built all the
expertise that we had built but as a
credit to our investors to our board and
frankly to Microsoft we decided to very
briskly move toward the super phone
segment and take a position of strength
in a position of leadership very early
on and and we did that so the second
half to ship on this platform was we did
the official we did a snow and ski
conditions app which was sponsored by
rei and we actually have updated this
year over year they're actually
sponsoring it now for their for the
fourth season and so you know this
became a very real media channel exactly
what we thought was going to happen in
2004 but as always happens with startup
it took a very different path to get
there so it's been you know quite an
exciting ride since then but we've tried
to retain
that sort of culture of innovation
around user experience in a round user
interface so we we invented this UI
which is the zoom canvas you I it's
interesting way to you know the case of
the Today Show they have all these
different content categories around you
know celebrities and food and people and
relationships and how do you create a
home screen that consumes that content
without it being kind of a postage stamp
home screen so we came up with this very
sexy sort of you know direct
manipulation home screen where you could
just navigate around this is all fake of
course smoke and mirrors but the point
is that there was a really sexy sort of
way to navigate around a very large body
of content very efficiently and it was
also very engaging it was a cool
browsing experience and you can imagine
how many advertisers want to be
connected with the Today Show is a brand
so this really helped us help to inform
this mobile engagement advertising
system we went on to do the official app
for Rachel Maddow also zoom canvas we
did the official app with the in
partnership with the MSNBC their
signature app use this very sexy radial
menu for filtering content categories
and that has has been a top news app in
the App Store now for for several years
and we did in partnership with Microsoft
the official app for Xbox which again a
very attractive audience and it was
great for the Microsoft advertising team
because if they got in the door to sell
an advertising relationship for the Xbox
console they could also add on
sponsorship in the app for the for the
contest so it's a very very cool
experience this app was great it had it
wasn't an app for actual gaming on the
phone it was about the lifestyle of
console gaming on xbox so it showed your
your avatar the full-body avatar design
it had if a celebrity was online playing
would tell you what they're playing and
when they be playing it it was a very
very cool system the you know the
podcast all of that was kind of
integrated into into the xbox experience
and this strategy works so the nice
thing about this kind of an advertising
based strategy is because we have
aligned objectives with the partner we
have to make that appt stay on their
home screen month over month over month
we have you know when Apple releases a
new iOS we have to update the app to
address that iOS and the publisher my
turn
I not pay us to do that it doesn't
matter we're going to do that work
because we want to stay ranked highly
and we've had 12 apps in the top 10 of
their category in the App Store 10 offs
10 apps in the top five so the story
again has it has a happy ending it's
been a very exciting journey and it's
been cool to partner with Microsoft in
that just brief journey learned about a
platform partnership and a sales
partnership and a intellectual property
partnership and a content partnership
all rolled up into you know sort of the
ecosystem of mobile engagement
advertising okay so changing now let's
talk a little bit about what this means
what is mobile engagement advertising
what are some examples so it turns out
that mountain dew did this really cool
campaign they called green label art and
it was really cool they basically had
these graffiti artists they found these
edgy graffiti artists from all over the
world they had them reimagine the
packaging of the Mountain Dew bottle
he's really sexy aluminum bottles which
are actually hard to find their kind of
a collector's item and then they wanted
to try and create a brand experience
around it and initially they approached
us to do a brand adapt to do advertising
at the time we did a little bit of that
as well if the numbers were right we
don't anymore but they approached us to
do an a branded app and we said we'll
wait a minute why do a branded app in
the App Store and you're going to
scramble to try and get this kind of
youth audience that you're trying to
target with with this campaign whereas
we have you know almost a million users
that are partying on the Xbox app every
day why not leverage that audience and
just create a brand experience inside
the xbox console that echoes this so
that's exactly what they did and it was
wicked it was actually to this day one
of the coolest mobile ads I've ever seen
so every one of these artists had their
own card just like the cards that you'd
see for a video game inside the
dashboard of the app they each had their
own card you could drill in and see
other examples of their artwork you
could read about their bio you could see
other products that they made you could
register to win those products all
inside the context of the app and never
threw you over the wall to a browser and
importantly it's so organically
integrated into the app content that you
know it isn't it's branded content it
provides entertainment value the metrics
were sick on this thing users would
spend 12 to 15 minutes inside the
essentially ad browsing this content now
the content was great too which is
important
for any ad but this is again really this
point where the performance orientation
and the targeting of of web advertising
really meet halfway with the creative
and the sort of energy and this kid
minus was done almost two years before I
add so we have been thinking about the
space for a long time another example of
a branded experience inside the xbox at
this was actually just last month the
official app of the or the launch of the
of the Ford Fiesta again nobody has to
install anything it just sort of
integrates the Ford Fiesta experience
right there inside your Xbox app you can
watch videos of all the features there's
photo social media interop you can
browse photos of the car you can save
them to your home screen there's a lot
of cool capabilities but it's about
thinking about branded content in the
context of an app which is very powerful
so this thing that we call brand blast a
big part of it was first thinking about
you know how do you have you sell this
type of advertising and how does it
express itself inside a nap so first of
all how do we sell it this is sold
typically as a fifty or a hundred
percent share of voice time-based
sponsorship of a nap so for example you
know without example I gave with
Mercedes and motor trend was a real
example where Mercedes they wanted fifty
percent share of the voice of that app
for a number of months i think that was
six months that was a really deep
engaged by so as a result we built hooks
in the app to be able to be skinned by
remote control without even going back
through the Apple certification process
so when the app is loading you get this
really nice kind of custom crafted a
launch screen indication the home screen
dashboard has the sexy bug that's sort
of a home screen bug to take you
directly into the end of the branded
content for Mercedes that can be
remotely controlled and changed
day-to-day week-to-week based on the
different sponsorship campaigns and then
you have this nice little popover
interstitial that after a very
scientific 4.5 seconds settles down the
creative as designs that it lives on the
top 50 pixels alone and then if you
actuate on on either of these it takes
you into this brand blast inside the app
never throws you over the wall to a
browser you can watch video content you
can do photos stuff like that and it's
really again
app within an app it's really engaged
content there's tons of examples we've
actually done a bunch of campaigns with
Microsoft as an advertiser as well the
Bing actually launched the official app
for parenting magazine last month and
then office came and and sponsored it
after that and again it's just really
beautiful and organic placement inside
the content and we have in-house
creative they're really lovingly crafts
these brand placements in partnership
with the agency of the brand to make
sure that it's you know really lush and
is not disruptive to the user but also
provides real value and engagement and
users love it because they get more free
apps so it has it has value so back to
this discussion about you know kind of
this new segment now I think you know
hopefully you have some context for for
what this mobile engagement type
advertising is and Steve Jobs can give
you a bunch of other examples and I know
that the windows phone 7 team powered by
Silverlight is partying on a lot of
other kind of these types of ads but I
actually think that this is one of the
most hot segments of advertising to
track just if we look at how our revenue
split percentage has shifted over the
last four years it's dramatically
shifted in this direction you know
people recognize that branded apps
advertisements don't actually perform
very well because you don't get many
users because not many people are going
to search the App Store for the you know
insert brand for their for their app
whereas mobile engagement is very
important search and local will continue
to be important Microsoft has strong
presence and Bing obviously and knows a
lot about that space but we really
believe in this mobile engagement app
within an app segment so then what so if
you decide you're focused on this
segment I want to spend time talking
about some of the mechanics that it
takes to be successful in this business
because it's a very complex space and
it's you know a keyword advertising
there are other advertising types that
are largely self-service from the
perspective of the advertiser but this
requires a fair amount of creative and
technical kung fu to really deliver on
this value proposition in the ways that
I've demonstrated so again the value
proposition is really it's a dating
service between brands and audience
brands and content whether it's you know
between Ford
box or between today's show and unilever
how do you do this so there's these
things that we call catalysts there's a
couple important catalysts to make this
happen it is not fire-and-forget sort of
if you build it they will come type of
advertising so the first is the
publishing strategy the challenge with
this is time frame because you'll get an
RFP for an ad buy that comes in
incredibly hot they might want to have
you know an ad in the market in six
weeks from today and you'll get an
insertion order for that kind of
advertising then we have to scramble
identify a publisher collaborate with
their editorial team you know build the
app run it through QA publish it to
apple get them to launch it and promote
it in six to eight weeks which is crazy
so we actually have work to refine a
system for doing this quickly and then
starting over to continue to refine the
content so this is I guess if you're in
if you're in the mobile advertising
business and you're interested in mobile
engagement advertising you are in the
mobile content business you just have to
be you have to be able to connect those
dots it's very important the second
thing is obviously as as you know you
will appreciate there is a platform
component of this there's a lot of
technology behind the scenes that makes
this happen so we've invested in you
know feed processing technology we have
over 20 patents on mobile content
specifically both on the client and on
the back end across multiple platforms
you know you need to have a publishing
platform because you can't build a good
iphone app really in four weeks or you
know or in some cases in two weeks in
order to get into the app store in four
to six weeks so we have invested in
platform technologies to be able to make
that happen and that sort of content
platform technologies are very very
important and the last thing is having
the right kind of sales strategy and
this is I want to make it a point to
call out how good Microsoft sales teams
are at this specifically the MSNBC team
who the MSNBC com team here on campus
the joint venture between Microsoft and
NBC the interactive sales professionals
there understand mobile engagement
really really well and they've been very
good at monetizing our
our our our content and their content
together with you know MSNBC and Rachel
Maddow and today's show and meet the
press and all those were sold
collaboratively with them Microsoft
advertising also I mentioned that some
of the properties that are not even
Microsoft properties are actually sold
by Microsoft advertising and again they
get it they understand this segment they
understand how to sell it particularly
as part of integrated by and zumo be
also has our own kind of cross a kind of
regional sales team that also sells into
these properties and we have inventory
management professionals that the
balance between these so it's a very
exciting time with regard to the fact
that this is a new segment of
advertising it's expanding rapidly it
helps to inform what's going to happen
next and I actually think that it's an
interesting commentary about software
sponsored by advertising I mean it
really has changed the way we think
about revenue we no longer do any work
for hire work one hundred percent of our
of our revenue comes from advertising
sponsored properties like that and it's
not just banner ads it's really
engagement engagement advertising yeah
none of the examples your shorter
proponents advertising rate they seem
more like brand engagement
Mountain Dew Mercedes quickly is there a
performance part there was a great
question totally I didn't actually
didn't show bang because I didn't have
the creative late last night I apologize
but the Bing campaign was very
performance oriented right it was to try
and draw downloads of the bing iphone
app and it was very successful i believe
that campaign ran in 183 mobile
placements and the parenting app
placement scored second in terms of
conversions into app installs so this
this model works better for performance
as well just because you as a user are
always more likely to click on an ad
that's integral to the app also because
we have sort of its brand targeted the
bat Bing creative add only ran on the
parenting app so as a result our
creative team the creative was about
baby names it was like search for the
best baby names you know like I don't
know what the most popular baby names
are you tap on it you just installed the
bing app so it's like there's a there's
a series of techniques for getting
driving performance we've also done some
hotel and restaurant work that was it
was performance-oriented that also
performed very well in terms of actual
bookings but it is true that the
majority of these types of campaigns are
brand oriented advertising and there's
those are the big portion of the budget
as well which is nice so I did want to
spend a little bit of time talking about
a couple things sort of talking about
what happens next I was you know sort of
specifically requested that I talk a
little bit about Windows Phone 7 because
we're we're partying on that platform
right now and we're honored to be on the
early developer program for windows
phone 7 and I'll sort of speak about the
platform in the context of mobile
advertising first of all I think that
you know it's a credible superfone
offering and it's really exciting to see
the team have taken such dramatic steps
both in terms of the visual language of
the platform that's clearly skews away
from the field but also in terms of the
way that you create apps for and I think
it's it's a very credible effort in this
space and I'm anxious to see how it
plays out in the marketplace and we're
excited to be partners in that space in
terms of as it as a platform for
advertising I'll candidly say that I'm
incredibly conflicted because on one
hand I think
one of the most exciting bold and
important things that that's happening
at Microsoft is this effort to try and
think about design and engineering
workflows specifically expression blend
Silverlight as a user those things are
exactly what I've been asking for for a
decade you know getting design and
engineering synchronized from day one
and taking these taking products to
market more quickly using vector assets
using you know real animatics not flash
prototype times all the things that
we've been talking about so it makes
certainly make sense that this platform
we so tightly coupled to silverlight as
a platform having said that it's a
really tough time to evangelize the
world on a on a plugin style
architecture at a time when people are
ripping flash out of their sites to
address super phones and iPads and other
devices it's a really tough time for
that so again i'm incredibly conflicted
about that and as an advertiser on this
platform I you know I didn't want to use
this opportunity just to and I know that
you know Microsoft understands this but
you know don't underestimate the the
power of don't have no idea but the
power of html5 you know this is an
important trend in the marketplace and I
totally appreciate that silverlight is
an important platform strategy and
believe me I know more than most that
this is a platform culture I spilled a
lot of blood on those battlefields but
in the K in the context of mobile you no
html5 is the way that we address our
advertising across all these platforms
because every one of the super phone
devices that I put it before renders
html5 beautifully and in fact a lot of
the content itself is actually rendered
using html5 canvas so I mean there's a
lot of opportunity there and shockingly
there's no tool chain to be found for
really good design centric html5 so I
guess my my plea my request is that the
world desperately needs great tools for
html5 Microsoft builds great tools I
understand that there's a lot of
platform momentum behind Silverlight
internally but I think that for mobile
this is an incredibly important trend in
terms of a ground truth of the way that
people are going to create mobile
advertising so much so that we've
actually invested in importing html5
brand blass
to windows phone 7 specifically so that
we can address cross-platform campaigns
when the platform goes live and that was
no small amount of work for us but it's
just super super important so I just
want to mention that again I fully
appreciate the the the platform
perspective but that's the the one thing
I wanted to mention you optimize the
html5 engines for multitasking like for
example if that's it there for apps
running html5 ads each of them is loaded
html5 the browser I really swapping
between those things and if you guys
they've gone down that part we haven't
had any issues and again most of the
operating systems sort of there's a you
know there's a broker higher in the
system that sort of handles memory
management and that does it quite well
and usually the first thing to go our
browser canvases even if you have
multiple browser windows open inside the
browser it'll it'll kill those tasks you
know sort of autonomously so we we've
never had an issue at all and the
context of a branded app only one brand
blast is going to be running at a time
so it's really not not an issue or not a
concern for us good question so anyways
that's that was sort of one point that I
wanted to say is that hTML is going to
be important for mobile so let me stop
talking for a while the timing is good I
wanted to make sure that we had at least
you know 20 or 30 minutes for an
audience driven dialogue about any
questions that you have about this space
mobile advertising in general engagement
mobile advertising and specific or
mobile more broadly so yes in done best
have thought about this how how do you
plan to compete with I ad or
especially I had goes together with App
Store sure yeah so I had this obviously
an important driver in this industry to
date it's been actually kind of good for
us because it's I ads are extremely
expensive and so there's a lot of buyers
who either don't have you know a
seven-figure budget to address you know
I ad but they might have a really they
might want to do this kind of engagement
advertising but more importantly I ads
are you know not for the faint of heart
from a development standpoint whereas
brand blasts are very straightforward to
build so we get a lot of kind of we've
gotten the rising tide lifts all ships
in this space and I had has helped kind
of bring attention to the other
engagement oriented advertising
inventories that are out there there's
another important characteristic which
is that you know with regard to
targeting we're not typically doing
these ads in a run of network way the
way that I ad does so you know Nissan
might go to apple and say we want this
general audience and Apple will but will
you know insert I ads across a selection
of apps that include you know there in
that audience or in that demographic we
provide very targeted experiences to the
point where oftentimes the creatives
themselves are precision crafted for
specific branded property so this is
also important if your motor trend
because if your motor trend and you
don't want to sell advertising you know
you want your ad sales team to sell the
motor trend mobile app in partnership
with us which you can do with brand
blast you can sell and you know an ad to
only express itself in one app in the
universe in a very targeted way and so
that's another thing that we have you
know from a business perspective we're
kind of run like a 1960's television
network where we're really marrying up
the advertisers with the shows in that
very direct way but without the drinking
or with less drinking
a good question
yeah how how far do you see the
intrusiveness of these ads going in a
few days from aux respectively the users
clearly distinguish that this is
different from the apt like that the
mountain dew ad it is highly integrated
into the platform they look like the
same tiles didn't care do they feel a
sense of kind of what you say intrusion
bar loose trusts if they actually
discovered later on yeah the web has
paved the way for that so they know sort
of the you know and actually television
as well now right it's like you never
know if it's actually a proper product
placement right so and massive with you
know video games I mean all the all
these things are sort of blurring the
line between content and advertising
which is important in the economics of
the ad ecosystem we do you know we're
sort of culturally very user centric so
we do for example we vetoed a lot of AD
types that are very popular on other ads
like for example when you tap on an
article and you want to read and you get
accosted by an overlay video you know
pre-roll video is one thing because
you're watching a video but getting
accosted by a video before you get to
the text of the adding we think that's
pretty intrusive so we don't do those
types of ads there's a bunch of types of
ads that I think we've chosen not to do
we all of our ads are kind of in a very
kind of they have a specific place
inside the the app in the case of the of
the Xbox app there's you know one to two
brand channels that are designated for
branded content and even though it's
right above or right below the social
media content it is its own
self-contained you know channel of
content so I mean there are some choices
that we've made to try and segment that
out but it's a delicate dance and it's
the line that we all walk and we haven't
you know if you look at the reviews of
our apps because they're free people
don't tend to complain about that and
the ads are also i think it's i find it
annoying as a user when i get like ads
on my iphone for ringtones and
wallpapers and things that i don't care
about but I don't mind as much if it's
like a really lush brand presentation
from a top-tier brand
which is all that we do yeah so all
these apps are in effect standalone are
you parked at all with the carrier's to
to look at new ways of even using some
of the advertising to offset data plans
or working more correctly carrier sure
we did in the previous life in the sort
of Zen Zoe days that was central to the
conversation was trying to figure out
how to feed advertising back into the
operators and you know some corner some
kind of an organic and elegant way that
the carriers that was difficult as I'm
sure you've experienced there's a lot of
complexities moving parts privacy rules
and I think one of the things that you
know it's difficult to overstate the
significance of the shift that the App
Store created in that frictionless
distribution channel but that's also not
pronouncing the carriers you know
obsolete they provide an incredibly
valuable channel and you know they're
going to have new faster better networks
for serving these types of campaigns and
I don't chance your question we have a
lot of interaction with carriers in a
previous life we don't even go to three
gsm now our relationship is directly
with the publishers and with the users
so
yeah looks like right now a lot of these
things have like a five to six week lead
time for you to create a new app
someplace like double-click acts as a
sort of I don't know clearinghouse for
lots of people to invest into and then
it puts it out into negative networks
have you thought about that model or
discarded that model those have
essentially and you've got a bunch of
things with with with places that people
can go in there and it figures out by
offshore however where put those price
yeah I'm totally not discounting the
value of that model that's that will
always be a huge part of the way
advertising is bought the question was
you know what about kind of ad networks
like double click or you know AdMob or
those types of models where it's just
like you throw a banner creative up or
throw a text string up and sorry I'm
being missing the project status me the
you know throw throw banner of that
stuff is hugely important but there's a
lot of people partying in that space
right now right so it's like we are much
more interested in the in the engagement
side of the side of the equation that's
partly because of where we came you know
the route that we came into this
business there will always be that
channel of buying advertising but that
channel buying advertising isn't isn't
right for every campaign so we're you
know kind of focused on the other type
of campaigns yes so I think they I
wanted to get your views on the future
of ha and marketplaces or up stores and
did you encounter a problem with your
current model where you are downloading
functionality without going through
Apple's you know process and do you have
a problem with a green to their app
store and agreement and where do you see
a app stores going into the future in
order to enable things like of course
within the five you won't have this
problem but we submitted apps you do
know it's a great question and you know
to your point I think you know that
there's a great sound bite from Forbes
where they said you know a funny thing
happened on the way to the mobile web
you know this crazy app thing happened
in that phenomenon sort of locally
cached applications and I believe that
five years from now you know you won't
really be able to distinguish the user
experience from html5 Interactive's to
native apps they'll be hardware
accelerated up location-based services
they'll have you know kind of robust
functionality but the app stores what
they've been incredibly good at is this
concept of curation right so you know
one of the things that's that that Apple
does very well is they have a team of
creative professionals that look at
every app that's submitted and it
bubbles up the stack and they promote
every Thursday the App Store flips over
and you can see new apps that are
promoted by them and as a user discovery
mechanism it's a very credible act of
curating the sea of apps so that you can
put you know you can kind of identify
the right app so that is one thing we
have a you know we have a monthly call
with Apple where we tell them what
brands are coming to the App Store and
we are work very closely with their team
to be able to curate that content
together with them but the we haven't
actually had any gripes about the App
Store as a kind of funnel you know the
because we're the publisher and the
creator of the app we're still able to
capture our usability statistics so that
we can tune the app we are you know
we've never had a nap decline for
reasons that we thought were
inappropriate you know so I mean I think
we have been pretty happy with that
channel and I I'm not on the short-term
concerned about the App Store being a
limit limitation for us because any
limitations you know the biggest
limitation for us is just approval time
you know if someone's to go live on a
date we can't guarantee
see that because there's a queue but the
trade-off of having our appt be promoted
if it's good enough and get the up you
know get the lift of additional users
discovering it and using it far
outweighs the obvious you know negative
aspects of having a curated system so I
think that's one of the cool things if
you compare you know apples approach to
Google's approach for example you know
Google culturally is you know submitted
its in the App Store 13 seconds later
you know it's sort of everybody can can
submit things and they also have a
curation cycle but Apple thinks much
more like again a television network of
finding it's a hit driven business find
the hips hits promote those apps you
know and and helped you know kind of to
validate that as a media channel which
is great for advertisers and great for
us so we've been pretty happy with that
as a channel yeah just keep it up both
maldito big model where basically you
have this explosion of possible
combinations of publisher
where I do guys I was really nicely
tailored one to walk that have you
thought of something in between any
where you have another letter in between
so you can kind of scan your content to
fit multiple publishers we have and we
this isn't live yet but we're actually
everything that I showed you here we're
apps that were published you know that
were coated you know on fifth and pike
in a sort of in Seattle lovingly crafted
by our by our team we're now galvanizing
brand blast as an SDK so that we can
actually get it out into more different
apps and these will still be individual
apps that we have relationship with
they'll still be very targeted so you
know you're buying that app the only
differences will be able to address a
larger body of apps still using our
exact same creatives and our exact same
brand block format in the exact same
places in the app just buy apps written
by other people so for example there are
some categories of apps that our
platform doesn't address games for
example well we'd love to be able to
sell advertising you know if somebody's
buying on xbox they should be buying on
whatever insert your favorite game so
that's a way for us to that's a little
bit of a hybrid model between the
breadth of double click and the focus of
the zoo mobi network and that I think is
is going to be out and you know sort of
q4 this year will start to do those
types of syndication partnerships with
with other advertisers very insightful
questions
questions how many of you just by show
of hands work in mobile and some
capacity and how many of you work in
mobile advertising
any other questions well again I really
appreciate your hospitality oh yeah go
ahead me more are you gonna also have
mobile Android I actually moving Android
now and in fact we'll be launching a
collection of apps on Android later this
year but right now we have one of the
top football apps together with our
partner Sporting News we have one of the
top NASCAR apps which I know is a area
of personal interest to you and I'm
kidding and so we have a bunch of really
really great apps in the android app app
marketplace now but that will be
expanding this this year again thanks
for hospitality and for the insightful
questions I really appreciated your time